goodnight and box it out Rubio look at a
push drops it off to the great shooter
Bridget's picks the pocket and put a
show tending and basket interference but
once you get under two minutes it's
Rubio [ __ ] that one away up ahead to
Booker drops it off the Jazz have almost
doubled at the free-throw line on the
drive traffic
keep it rising up for the quick follow
slam great turning the corner gets
inside and finishes with the two-hand
slam let us draw went down almost twice
Booker with the steal
up top to who brag who obliges okay the
fans were upset that first field goal
for the nets
[Applause]
this effect on this game the gang will
be Andre start to fatigue a little bit
here at Allen can't get in the game
floppy to kill you bring air mail by
Rubio
around the drive inside met at the rim
by Baynes who's doubled over in pain
created the fans bragging uber stood for
Monte Morris off the Denver bench goes
for the crush weight on top of Plumlee
he was not gonna let Plumlee block that
shot led brave
Junior detonated in Denver bridges on
the drive into the hands of Devin Booker
on my head to the streaking you pray who
gets up high and thunders in town with
the left hand this is the way the just
silence everyone Devin Booker looking up
he catches Kelly here is Holliday been
on the all defensive roster the last
couple of seasons Suns turn him over
again up ahead to uber a at Kelly rising
up with a soul-stealing left hand slam
on Ingram Kelly who Bray will dunk it on
you and that is two fouls on Ingram that
is one way to play some defense get
inside the lane fill great with the
steal Kelly racing up ahead finds book
up top to play a beautifully run break
finishing with a slam
[Music]
Rikki's Oh Steve up top to blu-ray who
gets the to a asleep better rebounding
they have come out successful with the W
[Applause]
it out stolen away by the sun's again
[Applause]
under Jim gives up the dribble do break
calling for it gets it Paul George it is
right here Beverly goes for the steal
and exposes Paul Joe got the young man
prepared still went away by obray up
ahead Booker drops it off Kelly with
those long arms
Devin Booker rewarded him he's gonna
stick it right in and laid it up himself
the outstretched arms of aten lob up top
to Oprah who rises up high and flushes
it would race his way down he thought he
would get it yeah Kelly look that there
was no kisses blown there that was a
full-on come up with their own defensive
Jim up top
[Applause]
back at her Kelly Oubre way right there
the speed and quickness to know that he
had to change speeds quickly to get out
I was giving the ball every time he's
gonna wave in his third year averaging
career highs in points rebounds and
minutes can't connect on the three yogic
inside poked away Suns get the steal
okay making a mistake bringing it down
[Applause]
see this is a mini he took his hand away
a lot of times guys don't get credit for
too brave pump fake on the three
[Applause]
the time I'm not taking that three take
milks out you take some of this we take
this back to the bench which you sons
this unable to get much separation led
by eight early bull gray with a steel
kelly racing to the web just to be
active in the quick hands by Kelly
O'Brien just flushes that one Linux a go
to the three mismatched but a great job
defensively thereby Rubio reads the
passing lane
Kelly explodes to the rim for the two
great foot on that Utah defense there's
a foul by Mitchell and really like the
way the sun's drive runs the floor this
time won't be stopped as he hammered it
down with a two-hand slam over Gobert he
wipes it out but then he finishes up
here and get